Iran's foreign minister Hussein Amir
abdulah has met qatar's shik tamim bin
hammad Alani here in Doha they discussed
the latest developments in Gaza abdull
ahan said that the conflict will not end
if Israel continues attacking civilians
on Saturday he met hamas's political
leader isma Han in qatar's
capital borsa Jabari is in Iran's
Capital tan dorsa Iran is known to be a
main backer of Hamas what's their
position on day 8 of this
conflict well we just heard from the
Iranian foreign minister in Doha during
his meeting with the Amir of Qatar and
he made it very clear and had one of the
strongest warnings from Iran that we've
heard over the past eight days he said
that if the situation continues and the
uh Israeli bombardment and aggression as
he called it continues on the
Palestinian the situation will expand it
will not be confined to just Gaza this
this is something very significant that
we have heard from the high ranking
Iranian official now uh for their
support of Hamas it's no secret Iran has
been a staunt supporter of the group
since its Inception and the Iranian
leadership has maintained their position
that they will continue to support Hamas
any which way they can and any which way
they're required to by the organization
itself and that has only been reiterated
over the past eight
days D said the US is moving major
military assets to the region first it
was one aircraft carrier now it's a
second aircraft carrier that's on its
way uh and they have specifically said
you know this is to prevent either
Hezbollah or Iran from trying to
escalate this has Iran commented on this
at
all Iran's position is that these moves
by the United States are actually seen
as an escalation themselves by moving
these uh major uh warships to to the
region uh it sends a message that uh
they are ready and uh willing to defend
their own interests and that is
something the Iranians have said that is
very dangerous because their
interference is what what is fueling the
instability in this region again I want
to point out something during the past
four days that we saw Hussein Amir
Abdullah hyan visit four countries
including uh Iraq Lebanon Syria and
Qatar his language changed quite
drastically from the first day on
Thursday where he spoke um after meeting
with the head of Hezbollah Hassan nah he
said that uh there is still time to try
and contain the situation trying to
deescalate but he did stress that the
groups such as Hezbollah and other
resistance groups were ready and their
fingers were on the trigger warning that
if this situation continues there could
be an escalation but not directly
threatening Israel on his last day in
Doha we saw him on Sunday during his
meeting with uh the Amir of Qatar he
said that the situation is if it's not
remedied if it doesn't deescalate then
there is no telling how large uh the
conflict will get and Iran along with
other Regional players can no longer be
an observer directly hinting that Iran
is willing to enter into this conflict
directly if Israel doesn't step back
okay and that's why we're watching it so
closely dorsa thanks for walking us
through it today thank you very much
dorsa Jabari reporting from tan